la situation reste critique dans la
région rhône alpes pour retrouvons à
lyon françoise vallée jean claude martin
toute la nuit toute la journée la pluie
est tombée sans cesse sur la région déjà
gorgés d'eau a lyon le rhône et la saône
ont largement dépassé leur cote d'
alerte
des centaines de voitures ont été
évacuées ou déviés à cause des
inondations
la circulation est très difficile depuis
deux jours les secours essaient de
remettre à flot cette barge venu
s'encastrer dans un pont du centre-ville
impossible avec un tel débit vous voyez
le courant il apporte quelque chose
comme 150 tonnes de pousser la barbe par
elle même doit faire 80 tonnes si bien
que les moyens que nous sapeurs-pompiers
nous pourrions avoir sont pas en commune
mesure avec l'événement cette nuit
encore l'e lerte maximum et maintenu
tous les dispositifs de sécurité restent
en place les prévisions ne sont pas des
plus optimistes
l'évolution bien c'est la crue c'est le
risque c'est la montée des eaux qui
progressivement continue surtout sur la
sones le rôle et leur légèrement
stabiliser dire qu'il faut que nous
ayons une vigilance constante vigilance
dans toute la région
effectivement après une petite accalmie
en fin de soirée les pluies viennent de
reprendre